lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
practicar cómo identificar ciertas
transformaciones las transformaciones
que veremos son la rotación donde
giramos algo alrededor de un punto
veremos las traslaciones en donde
desplazamos todos los puntos de una
figura también veremos reflexiones donde
volteamos una figura tomando como
referencia cierta línea y veremos lado
motes ya en donde vamos a encoger o
expandir una figura con esto en mente
veamos esta pregunta qué transformación
única se aplica al triángulo a para
obtener el triángulo b parece que ambos
triángulos tienen el mismo tamaño al
observarlos parece que cada uno de los
puntos de esta figura fue desplazado o
trasladado hacia esta otra parte podemos
ver que esto ocurre con todos los
vértices del triángulo
por lo que claramente observamos que
esta es una traslación hagamos otro
ejemplo de transformación única se
aplica al triángulo a para obtener el
triángulo b al ver los dibujos parece
que este punto corresponde a este otro
punto y este otro punto corresponde a
este de acá no parece una traslación
directa porque este punto estaría en
otro lugar quizás sea una rotación este
punto se rota aquí este otro punto cerro
está acá y este acá pareciera que el
triángulo se rota con respecto a este
punto así que claramente esta es una
rotación hagamos otro ejemplo de
transformación única se aplica al
cuadrilátero a para obtener el
cuadrilátero b parece que este punto
corresponde a este punto y este otro
punto corresponde a este punto de aquí
luce como una reflexión podemos imaginar
una especie de espejo por aquí y los
dibujos parecen imágenes reflejadas
claramente esto es una reflexión veamos
un ejemplo más de transformación única
se aplica al cuadrilátero a
obtener el cuadrilátero be vemos que el
cuadrilátero be es más grande así que
esta es una transformación geométrica no
rígida la distancia entre puntos
correspondientes ha aumentado y quizá
piensen que cuando hacemos algo más
grande o más pequeño tenemos una o motes
ya pero parece que esto también ha
cambiado de lugar se ha trasladado aquí
el objetivo principal es encontrar el
centro de la noticia por ejemplo si el
centro de la oms ya estuviera aquí todos
los puntos se extenderían de esta forma
este punto quedaría acá este otro por
acá
este otro por allá y este último por acá
aquí definitivamente tenemos una o motes
ya con su centro aproximado fuera del
trapecio idea y con esto terminamos